ah oui il ya quelques semaines lui faut
qu'on docteur de fl ou techniques pour
bientôt docteur de le pfl et co
présentateur notre podcast robust
libellé fischer a programmé et le this
2.0 une variante du jeu existe donc
hygiène mentale vous apparaît dans cette
vidéo le principe pelosi et de chercher
à deviner une règle secrète
d'acceptation ou de rejet des cartes et
comme l'expliquent hygiène mentale
on peut y voir une merveilleuse
métaphore de la science qui cherche à
deviner les règles de l'univers à partir
d'expériences scientifiques et de toutes
sortes de données collectées mais le
génie de lui c'est d'avoir en plus
rajouté une dimension bayésienne à ce
jeu en permettant à chaque joueur
d'effectuer des paris n'ont pas
déterministe mais probabiliste sur le
fait que des cartes proposées seront
acceptés ou non en combinant cela avec
l'annotation logarithmique qui est pro
on a noté comme on en a parlé dans
l'épisode sur les qcm bayésiens on
obtient ainsi un jeu qui nous défie de
généraliser correctement nos estimations
passé pour obtenir des bonnes
prédictions probabiliste saurez-vous
alors appliqué le bail à nice mme de ce
hameau nov
pour maximiser vos espérances de gains
bon allez faut de défier le démon de
solomonoff il ya quelques semaines j'ai
défié lui monsieur filles et hygiène
mentale à existe 2.0 et je vais vous
passez le replay 2 entre parties
endiablées et d'ailleurs avant d'aller
plus loin je vous invite à vous
connecter pour jouer la partie que nous
avons joué pour cela ouvrez deux
fenêtres de navigation web et taper
l'url et le 6-2 point web point ap
dans la première puis créer une nouvelle
partie avec un nom comme maître du jeu
ce maître du jeu servira uniquement à
simuler le maître du jeu contre lequel
monsieur fille hygiène mentale lui et
moi avons joué dans la seconde fenêtre
vous devrez copiez collez l'adresse qui
correspond au numéro de la partie vous
pouvez alors rentrez votre prénom est
bon vu que je le connais pas je vais
juste taper joueurs ensuite dans la
fenêtre maître du jeu vous devez choisir
specify vous louis d'al qods
contrairement à nous qui avions choisi
lettres et loses his popote tueuse de
roul puisqu'on a choisi de jouer contre
une règle choisis aléatoirement par
l'algorithme d'eleusis 2 et puis vous
pouvez mettre un descriptif comme la
règle jouer dans la vidéo
deux séances folles avec monsieur filles
et hygiène mentale appuyez ensuite sur
start km pour jouer exactement notre
parti en tant que joueur vous devrez
choisir exactement la carte que nous
avons proposé comme vous verrez dans la
suite cette vidéo la première carte que
nous avions proposé était un set de
coeur puis vous devez estimer votre
crédence en l'acceptation de la carte
soumises c'est là qu'on vous demande de
te faire une prédiction bayésienne une
fois votre crédence sélectionné est
validé il vous faudra revenir sur la
partie maîtres du jeu et pour jouer
notre parti vous devez accepter ou
refuser la carte de la même manière que
la règle contre laquelle on a joué là
accepter ou refuser et ça vous le verrez
dans la suite de cette vidéo vous
obtiendrez ensuite des scores qui
dépendent de la qualité de votre
prédiction bayésienne n'hésitez pas
ensuite à mettre en commentaire le score
que vous aurez obtenu à la fin de votre
parti
très bonne question excellent succès
maquis corse encore tous que je propose
une carte et à coup je me suis fait
d'accord ouais tu vois il a tapé attaque
directe déclare la carte a été acceptée
écoute c'est pas voir si ces couleurs
dépendance
kiev je repasse en tête ah non je
repasse en tête sur le dernier j'étais
déçu que l'udc aurait de quoi jeu c'est
pas bon c'est le plus jeune un peu plus
de confiance
forcément une bonne chose à voir at-il
lancé
[Musique]
du coup maintenant c'est à moi de
proposer une carte zap je veux pouvoir
d'abord défricher le terrain pour
pouvoir éliminer
parfois j'ai un mode de pensée où j'ai
c'est de confirmer
et puis le plupart du temps j'essaye de
me retourner moi-même pour essayer
d'infirmer je vais essayer de proposer
un truc qui je pense du coup va pas
marcher
c'est tout à fait vrai que le strich
parce que c'est moi qui connaît là le
gray qui décide des règles d'accord et
est maintenant je vous envoie un lien de
guitare le fichier qui colle
l'algorithme qui selon des règles c'est
juste une liste de les règles bah ça me
paraît clair comme ça on est vraiment
tous au même niveau voilà on débloque
j'ai fait facile moyen difficile facile
c'est les règles qu'ils dépendent juste
de la carte privilège c'est les règles
faciles moyens s'élèverait qui dépend de
la carte et de la une carte précédente
d'accord est difficile c'est derek ils
dépendent de la carte et de tout
l'historique précédente
est-ce que j'ai choisi puisque j'ai
choisi difficile ça peut être une des
trois catégories emphatique et les
cartes moyens les règles moyenne est
facile sont aussi inclus dans l'est
l'ensemble des règles d'accord d'accord
et pratique ça dépend des cartes
précédentes c'est les cartes accepter ou
toutes les cartes tellement l'écart
accepté j'ai les cartes refuser l
fastidieux à lire cette de règles mais
crédence moi ça va être sur combien de
cartes en moyenne sont du genre à être
acceptés là par exemple je sens que je
vais voter un peu plus parce qu'il l'a
quasiment 100 % à 100 % de nos cartes
ont été acceptées ok même si je connais
absolument pas la règle
ça me paraît très probable que une
majorité des cartes soient acceptées
donc que celle là sera acceptée aussi
même si je connais pas la règle ou
plusieurs cartes accepté ma crédence en
ce qu'elle sera acceptée augmentera même
si j'ai vraiment aucune idée de la règle
mais tu pas très stratégique cherche
juste à bien un truc qui seraient
refusés de jeu comprend une part fixe
est acceptée j'imagine que tu attaques
moins de règles au total dans ta liste
lui 30 hockey et j'imagine qu'elle fait
partie de ces règles il ya une chance
sur cent trente que ça soit celle là a
priori je propose comme règle ses
pinceaux des critiques mais que dès que
danone ou dépasse 5
la partie s'arrête et le la place le
joueur qui a dépassé 5 pour dépasser 5
il faut il faut faire 5 paris à 100%
d'affilée vainqueur schéma si tu as vu
si tu mets le tout qu'au bout c'est
quand même vraiment enceinte ces débats
gros codesa pas être un tu peux pas
mettre un petit peu avec + 0
non mais vraiment et en plus si tu
pourrais j'étais passé de monde parce
que là je parie que 0,9 9,9 même toi tu
es le tueur est honnête tu mets pas des
crimes en fusée mais qu'est-ce que ça
mérite et du coup voilà voilà ce que ça
je suis sûr sont en train de miser sur
le fait que vous allez vous tromper ou
qu'il ya quelque chose à ce que ce que
je suis thurial derrière que je fais pas
aller allée du dos
du coup voilà régler ces textes est tout
à fait qu'elle seule période
scientifique aura eu deux je gagne ou je
gagne ou pas il n'y a pas de deuxième
c'était quoi donc regardé j'ai rêvé mais
pas jouer deux têtes d'affiché ah ouais
il a cité sa lagune ait à gauche on a
quand même pris des risques l'une de
rien vous n'aurez plus faire avoir
alors après sur ce secret scarpa trois
figures espace si fréquent quand même
bon bah c'était la première partie qu'on
a joué et je ne dirais pas que j'ai
perdu je dirais juste que je n'ai pas
gagné
quoi qu'il en soit on a ensuite france
et d'autres partis et je pense avoir
progressé au fur à mesure dans mes
estimations bayésienne et finalement
c'est sans doute ça le plus intéressant
dans ce jeu l'éducation les médias et
notre entourage nous pousse constamment
avoir des affirmations déterministe ce
qui peut beaucoup réduire notre capacité
à accepter l'incertitude est arraisonné
avec l'incertitude et l'oasis 2.0 en
plus de nous faire remuer les méninges
semble aussi nous habituer à parier sur
l'avenir et sur les futurs probables et
à décrire l'étendue de notre ignorance
et ça dans le monde complexe dans lequel
on vit c'est certainement une habitude
fondamental à prendre et à apprendre